هذه اول عمليه مصوره لكتائب القسام قتل
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين من المسافه الصفر
في حي الزيتون جنوبيه مدينه غزه في سبتمبر
عام
93 ونحن سنخطف متى نشاء وسنقل متى نشاء
ونفجر السياره
المش نحن سنط نفذها ثلاثه مقاتلين ابرزهم
القيادي في القسام الشهيد عماد عقل الذي
تحول لاحقا الى ايقونه اعلاميه للكتائب
منذ ذلك الحين كانت الكاميرا بالنسبه
القسام
كالبندول في معظم عملياتهم ضد الجنود
الاسرائيليين الله
اكبر الله اكبر لكن الكاميرا نقلت عمليات
القسام نقله نوعيه في معركه طوفان الاقصى
الدائره
حاليا في اليوم الاول قبل 100 يوم وثقت
القسام بالصوت والصوره عمليه اقتحامها
المستوطنات والمعسكرات الاسرائيليه على
حدود قطاع غزه الله اكبر اثبتت هذه
الفيديوهات تصريحات القسام عن الهجوم بل
ووثقت تساقط الجنود الاسرائيليين في قبضه
المقاتلين الفلسطينيين بهذا الشكل لاول
مره في تاريخ
الصراع هذا الشكل الذي ارادت القسام
تاكيده ونشره بعد ذلك ما ان بدا الهجوم
البري الاسرائيلي على غزه وتوغلت الاليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في ارض
القطاع تنقلت معركه الصوره هذه الى مكان
اخر من كان سيصدق ان مقاتلا من القسام وضع
رايه حركه حماس على دبابه اسرائيليه
محترقه في مخيم الشاطئ شمال غرب مدينه
[موسيقى]
غزه كيف كانت القسام س تثبت ان مقلها وضع
عبوه العمل الفدائي على ظهر الدبابه
متوغلا او الصق عبوه شواظ محليه الصنع على
الميركافا التي صنعتها اسرائيل لكي لا
تقهر ومن كان سيشرح فرحه هذا المقاتل من
سرايا القدس بعد اصابته اليه اسرائيليه
بقذيفه اصابه مباشره على بعد عشرات
الامتار
فقط تحصل الجزيره على مقاطع فيديو لقتال
من المسافه الصفر يخوضها مقاتلون القسام
في بيت حنون وبيت لاه والشيخ رضوان
والزيتون والشجاع وخان يونس والقائمه تطول
لمقاطع فيديو وثقت فيها القسام خلال 100
يوم ان مقاتليها اوقعوا خسائر فادحه في
صفوف الجنود الاسرائيليين تعلن اسرائيل
تدميرها شبكات الانفاق في غزه وهكذا يرد
مقاتل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تعلن اسرائيل انها دم مرت 700
منصه اطلاق للصواريخ فتنطلق الصواريخ من
شمال غزه بعد تدمير اسرائيلي ممنهج استمر
يوم تعلن كتائب القسام انها قصفت تل ابيب
في الساعه الصفر من العام
2024 وخلال 28 دقيقه فقط تكون مشاهد اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ قد نشرت على حسابات القسام
الرسميه
صوره تؤكد بيانات الكتائب بتوجيه ضربات
دقيقه ومباشره ضد الاهداف الاسرائيليه
مدنا وجنودا واليات تلك الصور وضعت
اسرائيل امام حقيقه خسائرها الفادحه في
الحرب وتلك خسائر وثقت للصوت والصوره ولا
طرق للفرار من الرصاص او
الصوره